[Musik]
mit
der wald bleibt
jedem opfer schoss roman ein leben ist
die geschichte eines lebens das verpasst
wird dann eine kleine adlige aus der
normandie heiratet ein mann der sie
zwanghaft betrügt bringt einen sohn zur
welt der ihr vermögen allmählich
verbraucht und verschleudert
[Musik]
man kommt nie aus der engen umgebung des
elterlichen schlosses und der landschaft
ringsum heraus als dieses buch 883
herauskam war es auf anhieb einen
publikumserfolg
warum
weil es die banalität des gewöhnlichen
lebens in gestochen scharfe die polaroid
hafte bilder einfängt
der film den der französische regisseur
stéphane brizé jetzt nach diesem buch
gedreht hat hat im grunde nur zwei
prinzipien zum einen zeigt er die
hauptdarstellerin für die pendler in
jeder einstellung sie kommen überall wo
es ist immer ihre wahrnehmung ihr
erleben was er zeigt und zum anderen
hält er die zeitliche ordnung eine
geschichte die wir gewöhnt sind
planmäßig und systematisch nicht ein
das heißt er fliegt von anfang an in die
bilder in denen die geschichte erzählt
wird andere bilder ein die sie von
hinten her erzählen oder bilder in denen
man von etwas neues was sie schon nicht
mehr erlebt was sie verpasst hat was in
der vergangenheit liegt von den besseren
zeiten auf den glücklichen zeiten mit
ihrem mann mit ihrem kind weil all dem
was sie sich festzuhalten wünscht und
dass ihr doch welchen leuten
türen im ballbesitz schnell gehen
der test im cockpit
geschmack
der film ist also mehr die geschichte
eines gesichts und die geschichte einer
einzigen figur als die geschichte eines
lebens aber eben darin liegt keine
besondere qualität achten
[Musik]
potash an
er überschreitet die grenzen eine
literaturverfilmung indem er nicht
einfach nur aus dem buch das er sich
vornimmt sozusagen das skelett die
geschichte die erzählung heraus sieht
und sie möglichst kinematografische an
reicht soll er versenkt sich tatsächlich
in dieses buch
er versucht den kern dieses buches zu
erfassen
und genau das gelingt
[Musik]